hello and welcome to this video playing
webmaster SWAT italic so what is he
doing right a room far the worst
probably transposing into a different
opening Oh interesting
and it's probably preparing after c4 to
take well anyway that it must be the
roof let's not think about it for too
long and here what's going on here
interesting I prepare the fire stuff
Queen a4 is now wrong 95 is also not
great real interesting so let's do this
usually White has got enough
compensation in such a position might be
that we have transposed to some to some
known line from that from the Catalan
not entirely certain but it looks uh
looks like it's very very close at least
I wonder if he tries like f65 or this
injustice
that's not so easy to get get this
material back 95 is what he wants to
play I guess
so I can take 95 and win the Tyrael back
is that is that desirable is the thing
it doesn't really lead to much I think I
want to keep the pressure on
like here Queen b6
if it takes it I will have 95 that's
what I wanted to save it he goes with
this move interesting as I have to take
I was a bit of a waste of time
takes up the pawn row
just do this
Luke see for the idea and double
I think it looks very comfortable
actually from you it always has to be
enough compensation here I don't really
have anything better I can sometimes
just take your five and say okay that
wind is ending please with opposite
colors bishops but this is just some
kind of emergency action I want to play
for an advantage in this position if I
get the point back I'm in really good
shape yeah I take the tick on d4 right I
mean that doesn't really doesn't do that
much really I can take here though
and T 25mm I will take with the night
and you will take with the night
huh I didn't really see that coming
we have from the t1 c1 and playbook c8
something like that I certainly
overlooked something before that cannot
be the best possible outcome
and also take on D 3 of course
okay I will see 893 the end I have to
play Bishop back which is kind of kind
of annoying
time morning check
ma'am okay I'd let go f3 okay [ __ ] of
- he's down long time draw a third I
feel tempted but room of your own
not not to chest reasons but I still
feel tempted and okay anyway much insect
if I'm only has some way it's buzzing
okay so let's let's have a look yeah
Bishop d7 it's interesting it's really
interesting in school I mean I'll
somehow get and someone get get
compensation be 56 is given by the
computer
yeah I mean it looks like there's
compensation but the way this is a
fairly normal way of playing for
compensation in such a position
interesting yeah here I could have taken
on and play here I felt this was a bit
tool that failed to meet somehow and I
wasn't sure about my night I can always
get it back to c5 the engine likes this
maybe there is really no rook c5 now
that's not very Twitter should switch it
on
yeah you got combination you always
always have something but here probably
nothing is not so great really
so taking is given by the engine and
just like yeah basically try to shut the
game down now once you can get here now
I'm in slide slightly can go switch
nothing nothing's looking serious yeah
interesting games with this one
sacrifice okay guys thanks for watching